[Music]
it doesn't seem fair that only gay
people have to come out right straight
to default you guys talk a little bit
about what it means that young LGBTQ
youth are gonna watch this movie to
actually be able to see themselves on
screen first and foremost representation
for everyone is super important whether
that be sexual orientation or gender or
race it's important to be able to see
people who look like you and who are
going through the same things that you
go through it it's wait what it helps us
feel like normal and not alone and not
crazy this really is the first time that
there is a major studio that has made a
love story a coming-of-age story about a
gay protagonist and that in itself I
think is important because it shows
people that on a level like this is this
is your story it's worthy it's normal I
don't think this film is retin-a surly
representative of every LGBTQ experience
yes I don't think we as actors are
necessarily representative of the LGBTQ
community I think it's a step in the
right direction
yeah like may I just you know I don't to
be too presumptuous and say that this
movie is gonna change everybody's life
through suffering through this but you
know I definitely hope that if it
touches one person or two people or
three people over time that it still
rings true 2020 2030
heavys the hottest girl it's not really
my type not because she's black I love
black women I just I just love all women
the friends reaction I think was really
important to watch me yeah especially
Nick's reaction you know and what's so
beautiful about that is like instead of
being like whoa whoa bro like do you
think I'm cute he was like all right
let's go to a gay bar I think you're my
best friend this is what you're into
let's figure this out let's let's be
supportive of each other and whatever
our flavors are because that doesn't
change your friendship you know I think
that we have all these stereotypes
especially because of film and the way
that LGBTQ have been represented in that
and the reality is is no two gay people
are the same just like no two straight
people are the same and to be able to
see a different aspect or a different
viewpoint on on that is something that's
really key because there's no stupid
questions there's only really beautiful
compassionate answer
[Music]
[Applause]